yeah black now just repeating the moves
and white can't play on if white
captures that night black just
recaptures black would be winning and
black can't
yeah i mean it's going to be a draw any
second now that night cannot be captured
because it would end in checkmate it
looks like tournament over philia magnus
is going to go through could you go
queen takes e3 if you really want to
this is one of those very famous
checkmates and uh i i know you don't
need to but it's such a beautiful
checkmate and i think
everyone in their lifetime dreams of
getting this one on the board uh and
it's maybe worth showing you know you
take the pawn uh white takes your brook
okay we'll show that in a moment simon
we'll show that idea a bit later but it
looks like a draw there we go no way for
the white king to escape magnus is
through to the semi-finals wow in a
winning position i guess game four
magnus carlsen it ends in a draw this
game correct yes it ends in a draw but
that's all magnus carlsen needs he is
ready for
semi-finals in the area of things master
is liam a great fight but it ends in
court finals for him